[موسيقى]
استعاده التابوت الاخضر وعودته الى ارض
الوطن يمثل حلقه جديده في سلسله نجاحات
جهود وزاره الخارجيه لحمايه قرش مصر
الحضاري وانعكاسا لروح التعاون التي جمعت
مصر والولايات المتحده الامريكيه في مجال
حمايه الممتلكات الثقافيه واستعاده
الاثار المهربه
[موسيقى]
هو غطاء تابوت يعني اذا لسه في قاعده بس
قاعده لصوص المقابر
في
نقله في اخره واضح الغطا هو بس اللي اتسرق
لكن فيسبوك موجود في مكان الحفر الخلسه
اللي طلع منه هذا القطار
[موسيقى]
التابوت للاسف في جزء كبير في حاله الى حد
ما سيئه نتيجه طبعا خروجه بطريقه غير
شرعيه احنا ان شاء الله ناويين نطلع من
هنا باذن الله تعالى على المتحف المصري في
التحرير هيدخل المعامل هيحصل نوع من انواع
الاسعافات الاوليه ثم ترميم دقيق وده مهم
جدا
[موسيقى]